everyone's Jerry I'm chess cube gonna
play a five-minute game okay here we go
we have a 2255 player and go with efore
see what we have to face maybe the
Sicilian and here we go one of the most
popular defenses Sicilian defense so
let's go right into the open Sicilian
this isn't really like me to go ahead
and play an e4 opening but we'll work
with this so eats east six allows this
g4 advance so I'm gonna I'm gonna shoot
for this looking to just press forward
g5h for do I want to do that right now
however maybe we should just I'm gonna
opt for just some development first
there should be three and maybe now
chase the night or maybe retreat my
night to be three really don't want to
capture the night that would just allow
light to build up a stronger center so
I'm just gonna retreat my night avoid
exchanges I have a space advantage so
just following that general rule decide
who has a space advantage does better to
keep more pieces on the board so what
should black be doing here at any moment
I could press g5 and the Knights gonna
have to make use of this d7 square most
likely I doubt that it would want to go
to its home square and g8 so what must
black be doing here okay so g5 the the
follow-up after g5 is gonna have to be
h4 I believe so let's just go forward
with that the bishop and queen are now
hitting g5 so I'm just looking to
actually what am I looking to do this is
a sensitive point in my position c4 I'm
already sensing some night coming making
use of a five so let's prevent that
that's what's prompting my F for
advanced F for advanced to just Guard EE
and now we have this break in the center
so what do I do whenever there's a
potential for an exchange of pawns it's
often a very critical position so I
think I do better since I am lagging and
development to try my best to keep
things closed or maybe well no actually
I was just thinking of Bishop g2 but my
bishop already has a role of watching
over c4 so I don't want to do that so
now it's a little bit closed but there's
still possibilities for a break with by
way of h5 g6
in the meantime what does black look to
do it's a little bit tricky to get this
light squared Bishop develop I guess you
just have to play to d7 right it's not
the the greatest of squares to work with
but at least allows the rook on a to
play to this half-open C file my black
be also thinking about Knight c4 I don't
know what more is there really don't
want to advance on the Kings side any
that would just help me out I'm
anticipating castling queenside maybe a
5 as a possibility getting ready to push
my Knights around if a 5 maybe a 4 and
then I could focus on the weakened point
b5 or maybe Bishop before pinning my
knight to the King as another
alternative black is considering here if
Bishop b4 do i play my Queen to d2
essentially placing two two pieces that
are of greater value along this dark
square diagonal black is taking quite a
bit of time in this position hopefully
they have not locked off this is my
first game back first chess video in
quite some time it's good to be back
I've been busy with doing some things so
I hope to be posting some more videos
more frequently from from now on so what
is black doing okay pawn sacrifice is
this what's where's the compensation
with this I have this protected enough
what's the
this is this is the trick here huh
interesting very interesting okay so 95
hits the my Bishop which is unprotected
and there's pressure against my f4 pawn
so I can't just do like a natural maybe
backing up type of move if I capture the
knight the Queen recaptures I'm not so
sure I want to just bring the Queen out
so maybe I just take take this knight
first and then and then maybe worry
about how to do I want to capture this
knight actually what's the alternative
Knight our Bishop b2 our Bishop d2
Bishop d2 if I capture I still am up
upon hmm what to do here I think
eventually I would like to maybe play
Knight to e4 so I think I might want to
avoid the knight exchange but again I
still am lagging in development so
that's that's really what's prompting me
at this point to just capture so I could
at least get some more development in at
this point so Bishop d3 is on the agenda
Bishop d3 and I could maybe just Castle
queenside you know typically are earlier
on I had the intention of castling I'm
the Queen side and this was not I wasn't
expecting this sort of recapture but
okay so now this Bishop has a lot of
possibilities let's make use of this
diagonal and actually as a result of
this again this is another another key
moment as a result of capturing eat XD
we now have a four-on-three majority on
the Kings side I was planning on still
advancing on the King side in any event
but now it seems to be that much easier
so maybe f5 and I have a ton of choices
actually after f5 I could be playing F 6
e 6 g 6 ton of possibilities but now we
have this advance so these two pawns
either one can move let's just play if I
play f5 that could be met with c4
and then I'm gonna have to do something
let's see what do I do here maybe Queen
let's try Queen h5 to provoke to provoke
something queen h5 or is there capture
Bishop takes h6 check King takes Queen
out check I don't know if that's really
amounting to anything or maybe I play c3
c3 I really want to get this f5 advance
in down to a minute 30 what do I do
f5 mm-hmm don't know that I like that
actually all right I'm gonna go at Queen
f3 so I make way for queenside castle
and there's possibilities if c4 I could
have taken on c4 do I really want a
Castle queenside I'm gonna I'm gonna
abandon that I don't like that the rook
would be bearing down along the B file
so okay now we have this going on what
do I do
let's just capture here now this Bishop
I'm gonna go on Castle at this point
pretty much just have to maybe okay I'm
not I'm not afraid of this my bishops
are really guarding a lot of squares so
eventually I have to worry about a rook
coming to be - that's most certainly
gonna be annoying might maybe Bishop c3
in this position what else I do want to
still get these pawns rolling somehow h5
I want to keep this rook here and this
seems to be an interesting move okay so
I'm just gonna pin it now it's gonna
take with check I'm gonna recapture with
my queen or not alright let's maybe move
forward with trying to create some some
break on the Kings side here I'm looking
to maybe press g6 in this position that
all that'll create pawn exchanges and
this maybe I could put my H rook to good
use down to 45 seconds this is kind of
gonna come down to the wire may not even
matter at this point with regard to
material just have to start moving fast
and a few people are starting to filter
in
to grab the last two minutes of this
game so let's see how it finishes up
rook to be to my Bishop is very good
here let's just let's just go with g6
so I'm opening up this file potentially
for my King but I'm hoping to still get
something along the lines of this h-file
eventually I could maybe play this
Bishop d5 move if as soon as this pawn
moves and actually black is lower around
time than myself so it's kind of not
looking good so maybe I capture first
what do I do capture pawn takes pawn
first in between move if you capture
with the king
I would recapture it the rook all right
now let's get this guy doing something
if the bishop takes bishop I'm going to
recapture my queen so I'm just guarding
all entry points away from the black
queen and black is just down to about
what what do I do
just attack the bishop and then h6 maybe
h6 I'm just trying to not lose on time 4
seconds let's see
h6 we've met with g6 I'm gonna just push
this pawns because I want my Queen to be
able to come to a dark square with an
attack and actually this is going to be
very this is gonna be very strong h6 pin
piece ok so black ended up losing out
time that was a that was an interesting
game it's been again it's been a while
since I did fit any videos on chess cube
they were very kind of me on a very
recent note they gave me a cafe so feel
free to swing by the chest network cafe
if you have some time if you want to
check it out and I hope you're having a
great day and I hope to have some more
videos out more frequently take care bye